[Music]
i want to ask about your family because
i know that uh you have two children two
children twins harper and gideon
almost a year and a half old i was
curious about this about the dynamic
because uh your partner david he prefers
to be called he likes to be called daddy
is that right
well you know when it's too uh blokes
you know with kids you're not quite sure
what who's called what right so rather
than you know daddy one daddy two like
we're some sort of dr seuss book yeah it
seems better to have it be uh he's daddy
i'm papa papa yeah papa why did you want
to see it's very official
it seems like sweet children puffer's
home yeah
good to see you papa papa's home from
the cuckoo clock factory
exactly exactly right a papa just seems
like someone with a giant pipe ah papa's
home
all right children papa must go upstairs
to work now oh nice later
papa gets more free time free time
exactly
very nice you know our son's name gideon
and we were really loved uh uh the name
beckett
mm-hmm
i took that name you did yeah
yeah i i you know we nailed it like that
was like our number one choice we named
uh we named our we have trying to figure
out what's a good name that goes with
o'brien and my son was born we came up
with beckett o'brien because i thought
he'll either be a great playwright or a
bartender but either way
or probably both like ah
brian he'll be fine you have a becket
and then melissa etheridge has a becket
there were just too many celebrity baby
becketts they all came after me i'm
convinced of it we were the first ones
yeah they copy kids the kids are great
uh and and uh you know we saw this
amazing
what are you all giggling about
you ever find it's disconcerting when a
laugh comes for no reason
but i'm such a laugh [ __ ] i'm just
happy you just like nailed it yeah
sometimes i'm like well i caught a cold
over the weekend
i don't know i'll take it
can i ask a question how old was beckett
when he started talking
my son yeah uh well he's six now and we
think it'll be any time now
he just he can't get a word in that's
the only problem
let's take a look uh i don't know i'd
say well
no our kids are just about to talk
they're in the babbling age and so i
wonder when that's gonna stop and
they're now they go ah
all they do is abba ah and then you pick
them up and then they point at things
right so all it is is a guessing game
my wife and i were talking the other day
about how our our son you know he wasn't
saying any words and we thought what's
his first word going to be it's going to
be like you know
for son or just something really basic
and we're in la so a helicopter flies
overhead and he had never said any word
he was like
wow
and then nothing else for four years